le camping sauvage supprimés sur le
littoral languedoc-roussillon n'a
cependant pas complètement disparu auto
des saintes maries de la mer
si aujourd'hui l'entassement du mois
d'où ils résorber le manque de confort
et d'hygiène n'en est que plus évident
alors pourquoi ce choix
ça fait trois ans qu'on faisait steve on
vient surtout pour la liberté qu'on a on
n'a pas de contraire qu alors que dans
un cas on est obligé de respecter
certaines choses se calment bing dans la
ville oger
oui c'est à côté de la mer c'est plus
beau j'ai vu parce que je n'ai pas
payant en complicité auprès ya la plage
mangent les enfants jouaient du matin au
soir
moi même je peux même y aller enfin j'ai
beaucoup de liberté
on se dévouer on va chercher l'eau aux
saintes maries et puis autrement
c'est-à-dire avec un enfant petit c'est
quand même assez ça pose des problèmes
enfin avec le retour de certaines âge ça
ça se passe très bien pour faire la
vaisselle rue pour aller pour le les
jeux pour aller aux wc il faut faire
quand même parce que km
c'est déjà un peu plus disciplinés
chacun maîtrise et ses ordures ménagères
dans les poubelles qui ce qui se produit
pas et puis peut-être que la classe je
resterai propre dans ces conditions là
les poubelles voyez on a animé dans un
carton de me mettre à la benne et les
l'hygiène je vais prendre la douche aux
enfants koala aux saintes deux fois par
semaine quel accueil c'est un peu
sauvage faut-il donc au projet présenté
par le ministre de la qualité de la vie
d'un camping de 6000 places aménagées et
payant aux saintes maries de la mer
ah non l'année prochaine ou on n'aime
pas si on faisait payer moins après tant
que le camping restera comme ça qu'on
pourra compter sur la plage on reviendra
[Musique]